and then I start to walk on sweetie
flights and imaging which is actually
another dimension of imaging let's think
about this way if you want to understand
the life right you'll need to understand
two things you need to kind of
information one is a spatial resolution
right basically you have to see the
details or you have to see the object
and the other dimension is you want to
see the process you want to see some
things alive right because if you just
before any super resolution technique
for doing moving technique what do you
have is a very high resolution image of
that sample of a fixed angle at that
stuff at the moment on a plane that's
the most of time you can get I mean how
much you can integrate this life a
living process from result information
not enough read and then you will need
you will want to have the image live
dynamic 3d process alive with high
resolution and that's a different
challenge and that is a project I was
working on when I was in Eric's lab and
since that actually so the differences
between like something as a very thin
slice of some tissue over one moment in
time right versus they're already dead
versus something that's alive yeah like
Drosophila fruit right and they're able
to image while it's alive over time
rather rain or Sun right you interesting
about that are they oh you can say you
let's say you are having a HD image
that's a 4k image in your hands about a
football game or you prefer to say -
let's say - to watch the game at maybe
480 pixel resolution for for a Hanoi do
one play versus the whole game exactly
so basically actually one post right you
wonder you want the high-resolution live
video in heart process but at that point
of time to some 10 0 were some several
good live imaging technique but the way
that sports analogy
a lot right a really good one actually
sure one seeing one play of the game and
trying to make some inference about how
the biology works right versus watching
the whole game in high definition
exactly that's a really good yeah so in
the end we are collecting information of
the process life process right so this
and then that was the that's in the
motivation of my project are started